vision en ouverture de journal nous
allons célébrer ce soir et demain notre
manière le 20e anniversaire des
événements de mai 68 il faut savoir et
on le perçoit mieux aujourd'hui avec le
recul que les premiers frémissements de
ce mouvement sont apparus à strasbourg
mai 68 en fête a démarré deux ans avant
c'est ce que nous explique ce soir dans
ce premier volet et paul kobe ch qui a
retrouvé de nombreux documents
d'archivés
strasbourg avait senti passer le vent de
la révolte bien avant nanterre et bien
avant la sorbonne dès 1966 une poignée
de reder influencé par quelques membres
de l'internationale situationniste et
par leurs thèses s'emparait de
l'association des étudiants de
strasbourg puis de la mnef
au moment de la rentrée solennelle les
doigts years et professeurs trouvèrent
sur leurs sièges ce texte devenu célèbre
et qui contenait un diagnostic
prophétique de tous ceux qui exploserait
deux ans plus tard
face au scepticisme est de beaucoup à la
différence de la plus grand nombre au
laisser-aller et au conformisme de tous
il est certain qu'un groupuscule avis en
ayant un bain ce levier pouvait faire
quelque chose et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait pour laisser passer leurs idées
dans la foulée les situe comme on les
appelait alors dissolvent les bas pu les
bureaux des psychologies
qu'universitaire symbole pour eux de la
psychiatrie policière puis la braise se
mit à couver jusqu'au 5 mai 1968 date de
la première grève générale des
universités revendications libéré
cohn-bendit et les étudiants arrêtés
dans les bagarres qui avaient opposé à
paris les étudiants gauchistes et les
jeunes militants d'extrême droite
le lendemain les premières barricades
s'élève dans les rues du quartier latin
mais il faudra attendre le 8 mai pour la
première grande manifestation
strasbourgeoise
actuellement on en arrive à point de nom
le gouvernement nous accule à la révolte
il n'est plus question de revendiquer
quoi que ce soit sinon sinon une chose
qui a été définie dans la motion qui a
été voté ce matin à 7h par le conseil
étudiant occupant la faculté des lettres
c'est à dire l'autonomie diversité
pourtant les manifs ne seront pas le
fort des étudiants de strasbourg
vingt ans après celui que vous voyez ici
raconte je sais pas quel jour c'est et
je sais pas quand c'était exactement
mais en fait il y avait peu de il y
avait peu de manifestations d'ailleurs
strasbourg à cette époque là on était
surtout dans le cadre du palais u on
n'avait pas le romantisme des barricades
à la parisienne
ce qui fait que au fond on avait une
chance quand même me nourris à
strasbourg je crois c'est que nous
étions un peu par l'inaction à
strasbourg
nous étions un peu con année je crois la
réflexion et strasbourg était je crois à
cette époque sont trop me tromper je
crois que strasbourg était un lieu où on
a beaucoup réfléchi
l'autonomie de l'université de
strasbourg devient en 24 heures le mot
d'ordre qui donnera quelques mois plus
tard la loi edgar faure
les étudiants avaient à leur insu fait
aboutir une réforme qu'il n'était de
loin pas les seuls à souhaiter
mais entre nous demander l'autonomie b y
compris le recteur nous étions tous
d'accord sur cette question de lui nous
demandons tous l'autonomie et encore
maintenant dans l'est dans la loi ou à
l'effort qui a été votée il ya
l'autonomie des universités le seul
ennui c'est que pour réaliser
l'automobie disons administratives aux
politiques
je dirais qu'il faut les moyens avec ou
sans moyens et nous le verrons demain
l'autonomie ne suffira de loin pas à
assouvir la frénésie des étudiants
pour moi la vie va commencer
oh
au sénat
[Musique]